if you have to choose be the one who
does things not the one who is seen to
do things exactly absolutely I love that
rule oh yeah that's a great rule you can
do almost anything you want if you're
willing to take responsibility for it if
you don't want credit one of the most
effective political maneuver I've ever
seen I won't tell you who she is but
she's so sharp she's so brilliant and
she told me the last time I saw her
she's had her finger in pies for like 30
years popping up in places you'd never
expect I asked her like how the hell did
you pull this off and she said oh I
decided 30 years ago that I could do
whatever I wanted if I didn't want
credit that's exactly what she's done
and she's had a stellar career and I've
worked with other people who've done the
same thing it's very interesting thing
to realize you might say well why would
I want the responsibility without the
glory it's like hey do you want the
glory are you so sure that that wouldn't
just get in your way there's something
to be said for anonymity and second
maybe you want the responsibility cuz
that's the adventure you actually get to
do the thing that someone else just
wants to take credit for well maybe
doing the thing is plenty of reward in
and of itself